how often do you believe rape occurred I
truly I couldn't tell you it's about 1
in 1900 women are raped in the United
States according to the FBI it's about 1
in a, for college students you include
all sexual assault according to the
Department of Justice the Bureau of
Justice about 1 in 52 of all sex that
includes you know playing grab ass so
for me to be so idiotic as to not
believe rape culture which we both
agreed is the idea that rape is
perpetuated encouraged or tolerated in a
society you would need to present some
kind of data anything the only time
you've addressed evidence or data is
saying that it's the amount of
rapes matter the conviction rates matter
what we do with rapist matters you know
what how about somebody rapes you and
then you come and tell me that rape
culture is a MTH